yeah because like uh back when i was
like like newly into the anime community
like what there was a big like online
voice acting community when i was first
going to the anime community was that
still a thing when you were trying to be
a voice actress
um no i don't think so really so yeah
does japan not have like a
an online scene for voice acting where
they just voice acting stuff online
i think um i think some people do like
voice act online
and um some people actually like voice
act on nico nicole
yeah yeah yeah and um but i
didn't really participate in that
because i was kind of like
oh like well when i was in australia my
japanese wasn't
as fluent right like it was really like
it sounded like
an australian was talking about yeah
i get that yeah and so i was like oh
like you know i don't have much
confidence so i kind of practiced more
from home
okay um yeah i was like i was copying um
hanikawa from baker
nice yeah
i was practicing animals too like
so you tried to get the animal roles as
well
i just imagined animals
yeah like because on the internet
they're like you know it's important as
like a japanese
voice actor to be able to you know do
you have to audition for animal roles
um for me it was kind of like um
i already had it in my voice for you
and so yeah they picked me from there
but what kind of animals like just dogs
like dogs cats yeah i guess that's the
majority right
i'm so curious what was your what was
your process and like practicing for
that
i'll just like endlessly watch animals
on youtube
and then i'll kind of like copy the
animal
um yeah and that was there's there's
people who have demo reels for like uh
monster creature demo reel oh yeah
they're just like monster noises
yeah like weird sounds that human bodies
shouldn't make
yes i guess someone's gonna voice them
right yeah yeah yeah exactly
i mean there's quite a big demand for
that like there's always [ __ ] that needs
to be
rowling can you can you do something
yeah yeah yeah um a dog
it's very loud oh sorry i shouldn't
expect it it was great it was great it
was great my god
i could do a cat as well okay do it
[Music]
that's a cat that's pretty funny that's
really good
that's really good well i mean if we
said it was [ __ ] yeah
yeah i wonder if there's like any
viewers watching right now who has a cat
in the background who just like
yeah right who's throwing hands who's
throwing hands the dog is just losing it
yeah that's so cool